okay so for the selling how did you get
after Barry Bostwick money Barry only
cares about no um we we put on the brake
down for it and in his manager pitched
him and along with a lot of really
recognizable very delicate Gabe shoulder
at the pitches and I said yes so we me
an offer and he responded enough to the
material that he wanted to do it and he
came in and he was fantastic he was just
you never know which you know we cast a
lot of our friends in the movie so it
was a little stressful to have this sort
of unknown element of a you know a star
named coming in and is he gonna care you
know about like he was so prepared and
have so many ideas oh you don't like
that how about this and I'm on his own
props burn they were great yeah he plays
an exorcist in the movie and you know
the word of your props in script but he
came with this bag full of like all this
Exorcist equipment that I don't know
where he got sure he made it did he make
one okay um and so it was great you know
he really he just brought such an energy
to it that it was just great we're very
lucky done to happen and then the rest
of the cast you got it as well off their
dancers um the only other role that we
cast off breakdown was at Nancy lenihan
who played his Gabe's mom in the movie
and everyone else we knew okay one of
the ones that one of the advantages we
had is actress going into is that we had
all these great actors that we knew that
we had access to and you know so we we
can spare him very well and it was such
a relief not having to worry about that
aspect at all because we've done 50
plays with all the people that we cast
so we knew how they worked and really
the problem is not having enough roles
for all of our friends okay well what
are some of your rules on set those so
that I mean they're your friends but at
the same time you're still calling the
shots no one can look us in the eye okay
I was right that's very important more
used to that you know I've directed them
they've directed me it were used to that
sort of thing I think I think actors are
used to being told what to do so it
wasn't ever a problem and everyone came
in prepared and ready to go um that
would have been a problem if someone and
cared because we're not you know but
like all its my friends move ahead
already have tonight I didn't mean
there's a sort of a psychological thing
if oh oh I'm going to audition so I got
to learn the sides or whatever so but
there wasn't any of that everyone really
cared was excited to be there and yeah
good in real name with poems so no no
bad apples yeah only good apples okay
you